this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history and on this week's episode he's
taking a look at the military sim
shooter squad and meeting a few fans
along the way
[Laughter]
if there are any other games guns and
mechanics that you want to see jonathan
break down let us know in the comment
section
make sure to subscribe for more videos
like this one and if you'd like to help
out the royal army's museum and continue
to support jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
thank you all right quick pause there so
far so good i
do like the look and feel of this i'm
intrigued by the
realism aspect which this already looks
to have
a lot of so we're not we're not really
running and gunning very much
we've got the rpk 74 m
quite a good implementation of it i like
the the gas that's jetting out of the
gas block although that might be a
little excessive
i don't know that i've seen it do it to
that extent but i
like the sort of awareness that that's
something that happens
the actual usage of it is good but one
of the first things i i see is
a bipod being deployed brilliant we've
talked before about how light machine
guns
has to be fired from some sort of a
mount for to be truly effective
if you can if you can fit the feet of
the bipod on it you're going to be able
to use that
as a stable firing platform to actually
provide
not just accurate fire but suppressive
fire which is the purpose
primary purpose of a machine gun
we have the the pkp uh the petroneg as
as it's called
which is essentially an assault variant
of the pkm entirely appropriate to see
it in this game of course
and what i'm what i'm struck by here in
the
loading animation is some really nice
attention to detail
where the player character lifts up the
feed tray
and checks visually checks the chamber
to see that the gun is clear which is
something that
video games don't normally trouble
themselves with but
in any kind of armed force is absolutely
essentially part of the drill part of
the manual of arms
so that right there tells you that you
are playing
a milsim i really like the reloading
animation in general
here because it feels the
gun model feels like it has more weight
it doesn't just feel like one of those
um belt fed assault rifle like machine
guns that we get in first-person
shooters it's
more kind of he's having to manhandle it
turn it over
fit the ammo box put everything back
into position it
looks like it might weigh something
which i think is it helps immerse you in
what's going on
[Applause]
we've seen the player get killed a
couple of times clearly
very few bullets required to kill anyone
and i think i'm
detecting a suppression mechanic here
whereby bullet cracking past you which
you can hear
and although i've never been in any kind
of combat thankfully
i've spoken to plenty of people who have
and that that sound is
pretty distinctive um you've seen it in
more realistic movies like black hawk
down
you can tell from the noise a bullet
makes how close it is to you
and we also get it we get a narrow
narrowing of the vision and i don't
think that's from a bullet
hit i think that's from a bullet nearby
and again
all accounts from veterans say that your
your focus
narrows maybe not maybe not with a black
tunnel
but the effect is the same you become
hyper focused on what's directly in
front of you
because of the you know your essentially
your fight-or-flight response is kicking
in because you know that you could die
at any second that's almost impossible
to convey in a video game but an effect
like that comes very close
gladdens my heart to see the um the poor
old sa-80
in a video game generally so this i'm
afraid this just this
isn't realistic because the sa-80 hasn't
jammed once
um i just had to throw that in there
before someone in the comments did in
reality the l85a2 is an extremely
reliable and very accurate
infantry rifle of course famously the a1
was
not great there hasn't been any any
serious issues reported with
uh since the very beginning with the a2
version i don't
believe we get stoppages modeled
in this game i could be wrong i may be
proven wrong later on
so it's kind of irrelevant anyway but
there is there's a very strong
meme effectively of the sa-80 being just
the worst rifle ever
it's not the worst rifle ever by any
means currently as it genuinely is as
reliable as anything else in nato right
now so we need to move past that meme i
think
now i think what's really nice to see
and i think we're seeing both here
because it's a demonstration but we see
accurate aim semi-automatic fire which
is how how modern rifles are typically
used in combat
and that is clearly more effective and
then a couple of times we see some
bursts
at sort of medium range something like
that and they just they're just
totally ineffective automatic fire from
a rifle is not useless
but it's rarely used in many armies
today
so we've got a very good clip there
showing showing the use of the ag sa-80
at that's using the sights actually
using the iron sight on the grenade
launcher
almost never that doesn't happen in
normal first person shooters put it that
way
and i've never fired a 40 milligram
underbarrel grenade launcher but the
the arc of the trajectory of the of the
projectile
explosion maybe looked a little bit too
flamy
grenades typically explode without a
huge fireball there'll be a flash
but not a orange and black fireball
which we got
there so that one might be questionable
but in terms of its actual functionality
it's a relatively long range
quite accurate limited explosive radius
weapon so a real firepower boost to an
infantry
squad and very commonly used today
hey grenade or grenader that might
observe
any explosives on my observer right
there right behind that
we've got the g3k a4
specifically here so that's a 762
what people insist on calling battle
rifle which i'm not a fan of meaning
essentially an automatic rifle in a
larger caliber than an assault rifle is
typically thought to be chambered in
real world consequences of that
are a cartridge so powerful that you
can't really fire
bursts with any not from the shoulder
with any effectiveness but it does mean
that in a close quarters situation you
can flick to automatic fire and
put an absolutely devastating burst of
fire down this is nicely represented
you get the sense of the enhanced recoil
that comes with that larger cartridge
especially as he's leaning around the
wall and trying to put some fire down
it's
it's disturbing his position and hold
every time he fires a shot and he's
having to
correct which is what happens with
something like 556 you can keep it
pretty much
on and simply keep pulling the trigger
and just just as if by magic really
illustrating what i'm saying about
cartridges like 760x51 being too much
for an automatic rifle
our player has uh encountered the enemy
and panicked and has basically
sprayed all around and and not really
hit the enemy at all and the enemy has
got at least one hit on them and they've
had to run
and hide and get into cover that's what
happens if you can't
maintain your composure you can fire
very rapidly
on semi-automatic and you won't get the
same level of crazy dispersion as if you
just
posed the thing which is what happened
there so that makes the point very
very graphically hold on wait don't
there's enemy btr
right well you can't do the british
infantry squad
in the modern era without this thing the
l2 l129a1
sharpshooter so named after the
traditional
british military role of sharpshooter
there was a
capability gap between 556
rifles and sniper rifles essentially in
762
something for the middle ground they
found they were being engaged from
600 out to 800 meters perhaps
and they needed something to essentially
fight back with and so it's in the game
and it's actually a really nice little
show reel there for the capabilities of
this
this rifle so it's accurate aim fire to
800 meters despite the
very short barrel so that allows this to
be a relatively compact
weapon which means you can use it at
closer quarters as well and we saw that
in the game which is obviously not real
life but it's reflecting it pretty
closely
because you can simply use the little
red dot sight on top
and speed up your um cadence of pulling
the trigger
and you can essentially fulfill the role
of an assault rifle
and i think i think we get a good sense
of the punch of the 762 round there
as we see enemies in sort of in the
middle distance
and when a shot connects with them they
drop so
quite realistic
so this is a very afghanistan war type
the hungarian amd 65. so this is one of
a number of shortened kalashnikov
pattern rifles
uh it's somewhat distinctive in that it
has its own
muzzle device muzzle brake on it quite
simply this the pistol grip
is duplicated on the front and flipped
around to give you a sort of tommy gun
style four grip
albeit one that juts forward now i
couldn't
really tell how effective the amd was
being there but i got the impression
that the shorter barrel was definitely
a problem so we were less able to be
accurate with that but of course
at the sort of distances that fire is
actually opened often so 200 meters or
something it's perfectly adequate just
as good as any other
ak so it's easy to get too fixated on
the reduced capabilities
in this case of a short rifle but in the
right situation
it's really not going to be a problem
i think this is my favorite rendition of
the of the minime
that i've seen in the game the sound
effect i mean sound effects generally
are excellent but there's that
relatively distinctive high rate of fire
and i know i've been saying that
uh light machine guns should be used
from the bipod but a
556 light machine gun like the the
minime or a 5.45 one like like the rpk
absolutely can be fired from the
shoulder if necessary and of course
traditionally you would fire a machine
gun from the hip
if you're at sufficiently close range so
the clip here gives us a bit of both
we see the player mounting the gun
realistically on
on a stable platform on some cover and
giving short bursts
as you'd mostly expect to do and then we
see it giving it
some somewhat um more like that sort of
assault rifle with a high capacity which
in fairness is exactly how the uh the
249
slash l110 minimi in the british
service has been used
i've got a little clip there of a a
sniper in
helicopter and he's he's holding his
rifle in actually quite a realistic
manner with the muzzle down and he's
sort of
resting his hands on it i've seen that
done many times
i also know that would get you a severe
telling off
in many armed forces and is not
something you want to do
with any kind of precision rifle just in
case you were to damage the
the muzzle now in this case it's a flash
suppressor so chances are you wouldn't
do any harm
really a nice realistic detail of how
people actually handle weapons
and then it's kind of up for debate as
to whether it's realistic or not i think
it is and it isn't depending on which
armed force that you're
portraying so the rifle we're seeing
here is the famous
the dragon of the svd we've got two
flavors the standard version with the
long barrel and the wooden furniture and
the svdm
with more modern black furniture on it
and it's got a
side folding stock on it as well so you
can make it more compact
for transport it's a good implementation
of of that weapon it's almost like watch
it's at the very least like watching an
afghanistan war movie
and at times it's like watching actual
footage from theater
you can see how effective a
semi-automatic
scoped rifle of that nature might be
based on that footage alone so you're
able to
pinpoint people at a distance and take
them out with a single shot
[Applause]
potentially
i have to shout out for the ammunition
system in this game i really
appreciate this level of detail so a bit
like the old school shooters like
rainbow six
we've got accurately tracked use of
ammunition in each magazine so if you
take a partially fired magazine off the
weapon
it remains partially fired in contrast
to any mainstream shooter these days
it's quite a clever system so it goes
from
you have a number of magazines in your
in your webbing or your kit
they start white they turn yellow then
they turn
orange the more critical the situation
visually
the fewer rounds you have left in the
magazine now in the british army they
always
teach count your rounds so this reflects
what it would be like to
remember vaguely how many rounds you had
left in that mag in that pouch
or maybe from from the feel or from the
weight you might you would know roughly
how many were in there
quick visual check if you can see the
follower you know you only have a few
rounds left
so that is a really clever system i
think
yeah it's a rarity to see the c7
depicted in a
in a video game done a really good job
we've got the clamped on
picatinny rail down at the front in
front of the polymer traditional style
handguard
and of course optical sight-wise we've
got um in the second clip we've got the
big rubber of the sort of armored el
original elkan
sight the c79 um and in common with all
of the optics in the game that i've seen
the reticle is absolutely perfect and
the depiction of
fall of shots and how it all works is
excellent so they haven't just
reskinned an acog they've actually put
in the time to model
that optical sight and that specific
variant of ar15
so the m4 again we always nearly always
come across an m4 in any kind of
military-style shooter
fps and there's normally something i can
point out and say that's not quite right
but um not this time i can't see
anything i'm sure there's some minor
detail of the model
if you if you look at it under a
microscope but just from watching
gameplay
clips i can see absolutely nothing wrong
with it good job
so a rarely seen weapon the
c14 timberwolf rifle it's in 338 lap of
a magnum which is i think we've said
before
is a very powerful cartridge uh between
sort of 762 and
uh 50 branding machine gun and with a
lot of punch
so it'll go through all sorts of cover
so this
caliber has become the stan the new
standard british army sniper rifle
caliber just
getting rid of 762. the timberwolf is a
canadian design
so this is one that's actually seen some
some use and hence it's come to us
without its optical sight because
those are those are valuable and can be
carried over to replacement rifles
whereas the rest of it is at the end of
its useful life so it is becoming a
museum piece
um the version in the game i think is
being the standard canadian armed forces
version
a little bit different but this is the
uh this is the timberwolf
mbt
right we've got the rpg 26 rocket-based
anti-anti-tank weapon
and a lot of detail there in the
modeling and in the animation so
not only we've got the sights being
flipped up we've got the safety pin
being pulled out as well so a lot of
attention to detail there the sights the
iron sights function as they should as
well
don't have a great deal of experience
with anti-tank weapons but it's looking
good to me
something i do notice is that the the
sort of longer ranges that these
this anti-tank weapons being used at in
my experience of
first-person shooters you generally use
them at a very close range because
they're
you need some serious skill or luck to
actually lob a shot in at longer
distance
this appears to be flying on a flatter
more realistic trajectory and you can
actually reach out to i don't know maybe
300
300 meters which is which is more like
the realistic capability of the weapon
so
just in common with the rest of the game
they are going for realism first and
foremost
right a really fascinating conclusion
here is the
uh the ub 32 and you normally see
maybe two or maybe more of these hanging
off a hind gun ship
and uh if you've not seen news footage
with these you might think this is
absolutely nonsense it's not
aiming them is the biggest problem you
can't easily really aim them
i don't really understand the first
camera view we saw which appeared
it almost looked sort of doctor strange
loves satir
sat atop a bomb kind of thing only
you're sat on top of the rocket pod
which is clearly not what's happening
the exterior view of it firing shows how
it would be
remote fired from within the cab you
adjust the right the angle that you want
you know by estimation probably and then
you'd
fire it either from within the cab or
possibly more likely from a disc from
from away from the vehicle
don't fire it from behind or on top of
the rocket because of course it's got
rocket exhaust
yeah so i don't know i assume it's just
because otherwise they'd be unusable and
so they need some sort of aiming view
i'm sure the comments will explain to me
what's going on there
so yeah this is an rpg 7 v2
fragmentation rocket propelled grenade
short story you don't want to get hit by
it hello
hi royal armory
[Laughter]
[Applause]
superb so i gather uh our presenter
dave has been recognized in game and
a bunch of guys are showing off their
weapons to him and explaining what they
are
including an rpg loaded with a
relatively unusual
warhead that he's explaining and talking
about back blast and
the dangers of that presumably in the
game as not just in real life
that's good i particularly like the sort
of dancing about
i imagine whoever was in charge wasn't
wasn't too happy about
that little uh mother's meeting in the
middle of
stay tuned as ever on this channel for
more of this kind of thing
you can also head over to the royal
armouries channel for some extra
firearm related content if you'd like to
donate to what we do here at the royal
armouries museum
there's links in the description i'm
also going to be appearing
shortly on a film podcast with
rm military history and the armorers
bench both channels worth checking out
and they do a war movie review podcast
so
you can listen to me ramble on about a
movie for a change if you like okay guys
see you again next time
[Music]
you